voilà nous venons de parler de cinéma je
crois que il y a beaucoup de rendez vous
cinéma prévue pour 1981 mais nous allons
tout de suite faire le point avec nos
spécialistes en matière de cinéma oui
alors un effet parce que temps x
finalement c'est une c'est une équipe
qui fonctionne un peu comme dans un
navire spatial avec un équipage qui est
extrêmement nombreux vous connaissez
francis au sommet vous ne connaissez pas
nos deux amis nous de nos deux
fabricants dit mal si on peut dire
qu'ils ont donc la charge du cinéma
d'antan x alors quels sont les grands
points quelles sont les grandes
prévision que l'on peut faire ou en 1981
alors le film événement 1980 on peut
sans nul doute de dire que ça sera star
tricks motion pictures il star trek sa
retraite lui qu il y a de sortir aux usa
la semaine dernière il remporte déjà un
très vif succès car il reprend les
personnages très célèbre des trois
séries télévisées alors après star trek
effectivement donc il reprend les
personnages étaient de la série
télévisée mais alors il yad'autres donc
deux autres événements prévus pour 1980
alain carrazé tout l'empiré contre
attaque
la suite très attendue toi qui viennent
se tourne entre consacra à londres et
qui va enfin est en france et puis ce
sera aussi une production très attendue
c'est the black hole notre noir
nouveau film d'eva société disney qui se
différencie totalement des autres films
de cette même société qui sera une
grande aventure spatiale avec ernest
borgnine et maximilian schell très
grosses productions et bien rendez vous
donc en 1981 à condition évidemment de
ne pas finir au fond du trou noir
rendez vous tout de suite maintenant
avec francis rousseau vous connaissez sa
voix de velours elle vous enchante
chaque quinze jours et vous voyez
maintenant sur cette voie un visage un
visage que vous avez déjà vu à temps x
et qui maintenant c'est fait voit tout
entière pour 1980 francis quels sont les
grands rendez vous avec la alors un
trois rendez vous le premier avec
druillet le second avec bilal le
troisième avec mézières que nous sommes
allé surprendre chez eux dans leur
univers jusqu'à maintenant les pintes de
science-fiction venait à temps x 7 x 7
ans risque est allé à eux ensuite de ça
plusieurs manifestations importantes du
style convention de la bande dessinée à
angoulême
et puis aussi les autres formes d'art
dont on a parlé au début de temps x et
qu'on n'a pas encore montré mais qu'on
va montrer je vais parler du théâtre de
la sculpture ou même moi je souhaiterais
montrer des hologrammes
je sais pas si c'est possible tout est
possible dans le vaisseau de temps x
c'est une devise que nous ne devons
jamais oublier
je dis maintenant ceci que vous attendez
peut-être une excellente année pour vous
mais n'oubliez pas que dans 20 ans nous
serons en l'an 2000 alors c'est
l'occasion que nous tous réunis
aujourd'hui sur le vaisseau le temps x
nous mettons à profit pour vous dire
bonne mais bon siècle
également bon millénaire